to vote for president of the united
states is 538
within that whole number a majority is
270.
the votes for president of the united
states are as follows
joseph r biden jr of the state of
delaware has received 306 votes
donald j trump of the state of florida
has received 232 votes
the whole number of electors appointed
to vote for vice president of the united
states is 538
within that whole number a majority is
270.
the votes for vice president of the
united states are as follows
kamala d harris of the state of
california has received 306 votes
michael r pence of the state of indiana
has received 232 votes
the announcement of the state of the
vote by the president of the senate
shall be deemed a sufficient declaration
of the persons
elected president and vice president of
the united states
each for the term beginning on the 20th
day of january
2021 and shall be entered together with
the list
of the votes on the journals of the
senate and the house of representatives
the chair now recognizes for the purpose
of closing prayer
the 62nd chaplain of the united states
senate
chaplain barry c black